a man sues immigrant women to force them
to wax his genitals Miss USA or Miss
world USA dethrones miss Michigan for
refusing to wear a hijab and a-prime me
to smear merchant accuses disgraced
former senator Al Franken's female
accusers of lying we examine how the
left came to embrace misogyny then aoc
endorses open borders and president
Trump unveils the greatest new piece of
merchandise of the 2020 campaign all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today I did my best to
avoid talking about this giant man who
went into a ladies Brazilian wax salon
and asked them to wax his unpleasant
areas and then they didn't want to do it
because it's gross and he's a man and
now he's suing them out of their
business I tried not to talk about this
story not because I don't have thoughts
about it not because it's not important
for the culture but really just because
I don't want to think about it at all
but alas that's what we have to do here
so we will get into what that means and
why the left has become so misogynistic
but first let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project finding the right freelancer can
be time-consuming it can be frustrating
it can be overwhelming to managing you
don't know what you're gonna get where
do you go to find the talent how can you
be certain that they will deliver thanks
to Fiverr Pro finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
I've used Fiverr for a really long time
much longer than the daily wire has
existed and it's because when you're
working in politics and show business
and campaigns you need freelancers all
the time and Fiverr is just an
incredible marketplace to go to Fiverr
pros marketplace connects businesses
with hand vetted freelancers who offer
hundreds of digital services including
basically anything you need graphic
design copywriting web programming film
editing and more you can search it by
service delivery time price reviews and
more it's sometimes really complicated
or it seems really complicated to get
freelance talent but you can save time
money and you know you're gonna get a
good product delivered when you use
Fiverr Pro you'll know exactly what
you're paying for up front there's no
negotiation needed no transaction is
complete until you are 100% satisfied
with the work that you receive Fiverr
sellers have worked with some of the
most influential brands in the world and
you are guaranteed to receive VIP
customer support I mean I can't speak
highly enough about 5 or 5 or Pro they
just totally changed the game on finding
freelance service that you can trust
customer service you can count on and
results you can be proud of all on one
platform we live in the gig economy
Millennials and Gen Z embrace it use the
best platform check out fiber fi ve are
our dot-com and you will receive 10% off
your first order by using my code
Knowles Cana wles super easy don't waste
any time get the service you deserve
take five go to FIV ER are.com code
Knowles fiber comm code Knowles alright
wish that a dream could have gone on for
another 15 minutes so I don't have to
talk about this gross story but we do
have to talk about it because it
actually matters and it shows an aspect
of the modern left that is really
perverse and it's really anti-woman and
i'll use the word
it's misogynistic it exposes the left's
disdain contempt hatred for women at the
very bottom of the extreme of this
ideology what's the story it's a simple
enough story Brazilian immigrant women
living in Canada who have a waxing salon
you've heard of what a Brazilian wax is
it's when you wax everything everything
down there you wax and okay this is for
women so a trans woman walks into the
salon now the thing you'll know about
trans women is they aren't women they're
men
so this giant dude walks into the salon
and he says I want a Brazilian wax and
they refused him they said we're not
going to do that there are a couple
reasons why on the one hand I mean I
guess this is the most important reason
we should not live in a society where
men can go in to women's only places and
force them to take the men's pants off
and handle their genitals that's a bad
Society if your society gets to the
point where you can go in forcibly
expose yourself to women and make them
touch your genitals
you've gone wrong you've lost the plot
you've lost the narrative so that's the
main reason the other there's also a
technical reason why they had to refuse
him because you can't give a Brazilian
wax to a man
because the area that you're waxing is
different for men and for women they
have something they refer to it I think
is man's ilium that's the male version
of this but it is a different procedure
it involves different waxes it involves
different techniques so even if the
women were amenable to this idea
they might just technically not be able
to do it because it's different because
men and women are different because
there's no such thing as trans women
there are just men who were confused
about their gender or men who are
wearing dresses or men who very much
want to be the opposite sex than they
are I mean that's really what we're
arguing about here and and this shows
the the slippery slope of so-called
compassion I mean the left would have
you believe that it is compassionate to
indulge people's delusions there's
something like 0.2% of the population
that's confused about their biological
sex what the left tells you is look that
small percentage of population just
indulge them tell the man in a dress
that he's really a woman and and just go
along with it what could go wrong he's
not hurting anybody it's not hurting
anybody it is hurting these women it's
forcing these women who own a wax salon
to be exposed to men and to fondle their
genitals that's harmful to women yes
it's not harmful to the man man probably
likes it
the man is voluntarily going in there
trying to get it not only is it harmful
to the women in the experience of it
it's also forcing them out of business
so this this woman their business is
over I mean it cost so much money after
the guy files this this civil complaint
what is the guy's name the man formerly
named Jonathan yaniv he now pretends to
be a woman and his his name that he goes
by his Jessica yaniv he is not just a
guy trying to get waxed he is a
well-known activist and what he does
what his whole shtick is about is he
goes into these female-only places and
then he wants them to do intimate
services on him and then when they
refused to do it he files complaints
with the government and then he tries to
use the strong arm of the state which
has been totally perverted to
harm women into forcing these women into
dealing with his genitals so what's
going on I mean this is why I've had
people come up to me and they'll say
Michael why do you even talk about the
issue of gender ideology say well I talk
about it because it's become a dominant
cultural and political issue and
presidential candidates are talking
about it all the time so as someone
who's looking at politics and culture I
have to talk about it they say yeah but
why do you have to say that men can't be
women who is it really hurting now look
this is a very tangible example of who's
being hurt by this ideology but this
isn't the reason I mean that the reason
to say that men are not women is not
because a Brazilian wax shop owner gets
hurt sometimes the reason is because it
is true that men are not women and when
you deal in lies when you allow yourself
to be taken in by fantasies even if it
seems innocent enough at first true is
it gonna hurt you're talking about 0.2%
of the population it's not a big deal
forget about it even though it's see
it's so tempting I mean that's the
temptation to deal in well it's just a
little white lie it's just a little
fantasy it's easier it's easier than
dealing in the reality but then you go
down the line and all of a sudden
yeah maybe these immigrant wax owners
are gonna be hurt and then you go
further down the line and what you now
have in Canada and soon to be in the
United States is men using the strong
arm of the state to force women into
seeing their genitals to force women
into very uncomfortable abusive bizarre
creepy weird situations by the force of
government touch this dudes genitals or
lose your business that's what the state
in Canada told this Brazilian immigrant
so he's fought this guy's filed 15
complaints with esthetician if this is
the way that's the word for beauty like
people who deal in beauty esthetician
he's filed 15 complaints with this
British Columbia
Human Rights Tribunal seeking financial
restitution and the discrimination that
he claims this gender identity the
reason I say that this is coming to the
United States is there are actually
cases in the pipeline right now on their
way to the Supreme Court that are going
to pose this question to the highest
court in the United States in the United
States and Canada and elsewhere we have
certain protections against
discrimination so we have protections
against discrimination on race
we have protest some protections against
discrimination on religion and we have
protections against discrimination on
the basis of sex this is the whole idea
of title 9 tie all these different laws
that were passed in the 1960s so you
already have laws against discrimination
on the basis of sex now what they want
to add is protections against
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity but to have laws protecting
against discrimination on the basis of
gender identity destroys the laws that
protect against discrimination on the
basis of sex here's a very simple
version of this speaking of title 9
speaking of all of these protections
particularly at schools you know female
sports in high school or in college we
have different sports for men and women
and boys and girls in high school and
the reason is men are physically
stronger than women and they're faster
than women and so if you had men
competing against women in let's say
high school track the men are gonna win
and the women are gonna lose and then
they don't get their scholarships and
they don't get their trophies and they
don't get to go to the championship and
really they might as well not compete so
if you that's why we have these
protections on the basis of sex and that
creates female girls high school track
the minute that you have a protection on
the basis of gender identity you no
longer have the protection on the basis
of sex because men are now allowed to
compete in the girls high school track
and guess what's going to happen they're
gonna win that's what we've been seeing
happening in Connecticut and there are
cases now moving all the way up in the
pipeline of the courts that are going to
to determine this are we going to be a
society that protects people on the
basis of sex are we gonna be a society
that protects people on the basis of
imagination which is to say does not
protect women and does prefer men that's
the question that we're going to have to
answer and the left has embraced the
gender identity they're ignoring the sex
now they're done with sex sex was useful
to them when they were dividing people
up on feminism in the 1960s and 70s now
that's over they're talking about gender
identity don't take my word for it take
the words of the Democratic candidates
for president we'll get to what they
have to say in a second but first
support for the Michael Nolt show comes
from our friends at rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans finding the right house is
not easy and I would know that because I
live in LA and LA every house you want
to buy is like seven zillion dollars in
every neighborhood is you know they're
so particular however once I do find a
house I can at least rest easy because
finding the right mortgage will be easy
too rocket mortgage makes it easy their
team of mortgage experts is obsessed
with finding a better way that means
that their number one goal is to make
the home buying process smoother for you
industry-leading online lending
technology developed in the heart of
Detroit rocket mortgage is changing the
game they make the home buying process
work for you and rocket mortgage is
there with award-winning client service
and support every step of the way their
team cares about getting you home into
the home of your dreams
and that's why Quicken Loans is ranked
highest in customer satisfaction for
primary mortgage origination nine years
in a row highest in mortgage servicing
five years in a row you know people
don't learn anything anymore
any of the they learn about like gender
ideology and like ballet and all these
you know super duper ballet scientific
studies they don't actually learn about
practical things like getting a mortgage
or doing your taxes I don't know any of
those things fortunately rocket
mortgages there because rocket mortgage
is more than just a lender get started
online at rocket mortgage calm slash
Knolls KO wles Equal Housing lender
licensed in all 50 states n MLS consumer
access door number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage simple as that the
left has made their choice they're
picking gender ideology as
new protected class which means they are
ditching sex as the old protected class
and they're doing it on their Twitter
accounts and they're doing it at the
Presidential Debates
so three Democratic candidates for
president have now added their preferred
pronouns to their Twitter account and
obviously this is kind of just some
silly virtue signaling to the woke left
but the premise of the pronouns the
preferred pronouns is that it is
entirely possible that they identify as
a sex that is not their actual sex
the idea being my name is Michael
Knowles I have an Adam's apple I have a
pretty deep voice I'm not a hulking
adonis of a man but I'm at least
recognizable as a man bone structure
that sort of thing other things too I
don't go into wax salon so I won't get
into it it is entirely plausible under
the pronoun preferred pronoun regime
that I could say my preferred pronouns
are she and her and you would have to
refer to me that way that's what
elizabeth warren is doing she added she
and her to her Twitter account actually
what she first did is that she and hers
the the possessive of it and she did it
because she's just an old white boomer
lady who really all she wants to do is
be cool and woke and super hip and she
just isn't you know she's she's like the
mom on Mean Girls I'm not a regular
presidential candidate I'm a cool
presidential candidate you know but then
she just gets it wrong so she's edited
that since she's NASA's she and her not
to be outdone bill de blasio who I
completely forgot was in the
presidential race current Bolshevik
mayor of New York he added he and him
just so good I was confused I didn't
know if I was gonna call this like
tough-talking tall New York mayor I
don't know if I was gonna call him a
little girl or something I was gonna
call him she but he adds this to because
he is like Elizabeth Warren always
positioned himself as a far left-wing
candidate and on the progressive and
woke side of the Democratic Party but I
have to say they both got out woked
Warren and Bill DeBlasio they got out
woked
by who Leon Castro who said that his
preferred pronouns are he/him and L ooh
Spanish woke that's so much more woke
than those two white people those two
knuckle draggers they didn't even add a
Spanish pronoun L there's there is like
a kind of esoteric message here by the
way it took is L it's also a word for
God
you know like L l Allah or L has it
means God and so I do like this idea
that we are playing God when we are
trying to say I can recreate myself I'm
a man but I will recreate myself as a
woman I have total power over my nature
and my circumstances I mean that is the
implicit premise that the left is
talking about and it's coincidentally
being expressed in those pronouns but
according he has these preferred
pronouns there but even that wasn't woke
enough even the Spanish pronoun wasn't
work enough because according to the New
York magazine reporter Olivia newsy this
is what she tweeted out quote at a
Planned Parenthood event a non-binary
activist that's an activist who doesn't
think that he's either a man or woman
he's some combination or neither
whatever a non-binary activist just
asked Castro how he'll expand sexual and
reproductive health for trans people
Castro responds by first asking which
pronoun the activist prefers they
replied I actually don't use any
pronouns which received some applause
ooh I don't use any pronoun so pretty
soon Castro is gonna have to delete
those pronouns because the new woke
thing for the last five minutes
the woke thing has been to add your
preferred pronouns but pretty soon that
is going to become bigoted and
transphobic and homophobic and whatever
phobic and so now the new one is going
to be erasing all distinctions
whatsoever which is what this is really
boiling down to any distinction between
any sort of human person is going to be
wiped away and we'll see what that means
for women in
just a second but Castro is the vanguard
he is leading the way here you remember
in that first Democratic presidential
debate when everyone else was endorsing
abortion on demand paid for by taxpayers
without apology up until the point of
birth Castro took it a step further and
he endorsed abortion for biological men
reproductive freedom I believe in
reproductive justice what that means is
that just because a woman or let's also
not forget someone in the trans
community a trans female is poor doesn't
mean they shouldn't have the right to
exercise that right to choose and so I
absolutely would cover the right to have
an abortion
that's right whoo yeah you're endorsing
abortions for man I mean this shows a
little bit of his ignorance here because
he wants to seem like the locust
candidate so he says I don't believe in
reproductive freedom I believe in
reproductive justice you say well Julian
Castro what's the difference I don't
know but one sounds really serious and
then he says we need to not forget about
trans women and I think what he meant to
say was trans men trans men is the term
to refer to women who dress like men and
so obviously trans men which really just
women can still have babies because they
have a uterus and they're women but
trans women cannot have babies because
they're men and in Canada they can't get
Brazilian waxes either because they're
men they kid they're not women he got
that a little bit confused or he's
endorsing abortions for men I don't know
which is worse point is gender identity
as a category is essentially a
misogynistic idea because it erases
women I think now this is taught in
schools as though it's just obvious that
there is biological sex and gender
identity and that those are totally
separate no there is no such thing as
gender identity this is a completely
fictional concept that is invented by
misogynistic ideologues who are erasing
women the left talks about erasure right
and I usually they use it in a silly way
this is one example where it's true
where it's actually happening where
gender identity is erasing women gender
ideology erases women what is a woman
what is a woman just ask yourself I mean
anybody who embraces the gender ideology
just that what is a woman well I know
that I'm a woman okay how do you know
that you're a woman
I just know deep down okay well I don't
know that you're a woman if you're a man
who says you're a woman how how can you
convince me that you even know what it
is to be a woman what you're really
saying then is that men have the right
to define what it is to be a woman now
I'll give you a very basic answer of
what is a woman a person who isn't a man
I'll give you a definition of what a man
is is a person who isn't a woman sexual
difference the difference between men
and women is fundamental to who we are
that's why it appears at the very
beginning of every creation story within
the first chapters of Genesis you have
sexual difference Eve pulled from Adam's
rib complementary to him different but
she complements him gilgamesh sexual
difference right in the beginning
there's a reason this is essential to
who we are if there is no sexual
difference then there is no such thing
as women right if there's no biological
or spiritual or whatever kind of
difference between the two types of
human beings then there's only one type
and you can call that type man or you
can call that type woman or you can call
it type whatever but there's only one
there isn't that difference so gender
ideology seeks this kind of bizarre
conformity right now you might say well
it's not just that it erases women maybe
it actually preserves women and it
erases men you ever think about that
Michael it doesn't because when you
erase sexual difference this naturally I
would I would daresay inevitably
redounds to the benefit of men
how do I know that well because we
started to see that in the 1960s and 70s
with second wave feminism second wave
feminism which rejected all traditional
ideas of femininity rejected all kind of
traditional gender roles but what did it
do in the name of women's liberation it
said that women had to just start
behaving like men women couldn't stay at
home women couldn't raise children women
shouldn't have children really at all in
many cases women should go work 100
hours a week
women should compete in physical sports
all the time women should be drafted to
join the military women should do things
that for perfectly natural reasons men
are more geared toward when men and
women compete physically what happens
then win and women are erased when men
and women compete professionally men
often win not all the time not saying
women can't be perfectly competent and
expert professionals and extraordinarily
ambitious and rise to the top of their
fields I'm not saying that I'm saying
that generally speaking when men and
women compete professionally men win for
natural reasons because men tend to be
more professionally inclined more
professionally focused they want to
spend more time at work they want to
dedicate more of their mental energy to
their jobs they're more single-minded
they're they're less able to keep track
of lots of different things they're
they're generally less organized men are
generally less nurturing and the
biological fact is men are unable to
conceive life so women naturally can
conceive life and in most cases they
want to conceive life and they want to
nurture and they want to raise children
so there is a natural professional
advantage to men and feminism set the
stage for this gender ideology by
exalting traditionally male attributes /
female attributes now but you know
people look at transgenderism and
feminism as completely opposed to one
another in many ways they are feminism
seeks to allow women to define what it
is to be a woman
transgender ideology says there's no
such thing as men and women and by the
way men can define what womanhood is
they seem opposed
gender ideology is built on feminism
when feminism in the 1960s exalted well
every male attribute male
characteristics male preferences over
traditionally traditional ideas of
femininity gender ideology came in as
the sucker punch at the end and finished
off the job and so you're in this very
awful situation where men and women are
now competing with one another and it's
it's resulting in wax salons and Canada
being shut down because women won't
agree to fondle men's genitals even if
the men are wearing a dress the
traditional view of course is that men
and women aren't supposed to compete we
don't compete with each other men and
women are supposed to love each other
men and women are made for each other
that statement is probably gonna be
banned as hate speech I'm probably gonna
use lose my youtube channel because of
that but that's that's the traditional
idea I'm not in competition with women I
love women you know the old line is
there will never be a gender war because
everybody's sleeping with the enemy
that's true it should be true but hatred
of women and hatred of womanhood is on
the rise on the left you see it not just
in whack salons in Canada you see it not
just in the the presidential debates you
see it in the Miss World USA pageant
Miss Michigan of me you know it's a
little confusing cuz they're like 20
different Miss America's now there's
Miss America Miss Universe Miss world
USA so this one the latter miss world
USA has stripped miss Michigan of her
crown and the reason they did it is
because she refused to wear the hijab
she refused to submit herself to an
oppressive and alien religions practices
for women she's not Muslim
she has no obligation to wear the hijab
and she objects to the hijab on
religious and ethical grounds because it
is used throughout the world as a tool
of women's oppression she's 20 years old
this girl she is a conservative activist
she's a trump supporter her name is
Kathy you she's also a woman of color to
use the left's term
she is a Chinese immigrant she came here
at age five she should check every box
that the left is supposed to like except
the left increasingly hates women I
don't know if they're consciously hating
women I'm not accusing them of that I'm
saying the logical conclusion of their
perverted ideology is resulting in
misogyny it is saying you a young
immigrant woman of color we will destroy
your reputation and take away your job
if you don't refuse if you don't wear a
foreign religious symbol of women's
oppression think about how crazy that is
this is all in the name of locusts
he or she is describing what happened
there's a try a hijab on booth at my
college campus so you're telling me that
it's now just a fashion accessory and
not a religious thing or are you just
trying to get women used to being
oppressed under Islam again yeah you
know what we'd like to say about that
you don't see how that could be
offensive not at all um they were you
know that I went past the booth I was
late for class ready they were saying to
wanna put on a shop putting it you know
over me I said no I don't want to I
declined wearing this you know garment I
think that you know it's really rude I
feel like two Muslims to that you know
to wear their sacred garment on someone
who isn't a Muslim themselves you know I
I don't I wouldn't want to put you know
a Catholic rosary on someone if they
aren't Catholic right but I think about
what you said what you said it wasn't
that you felt badly for them that you
weren't Muslim it's that you said or are
you just trying to get women used to
being oppressed under it there are there
are so many women in Muslim countries
right now who are being stoned to death
because they don't want to wear a hijab
do you see their husbands requirement to
do so and I think that we should be
focusing on that way more than the
Western things about Muslim because you
know there's there's so many bad things
happening in Muslim countries because of
these you know women and and these women
are being you know crucified for not
wearing a hijab and I think that's
really really awful the hijab is used as
a tool of women's oppression all around
the world she's completely correct and
this woman on CNN can't
leave it she's she's shaming her for
refusing to wear the hijab a symbol of a
foreign religion in which he doesn't
believe used to put down women we'll get
to how this all comes together I mean
what this really leads to in a very
practical political way he is the left
which has led me to now for how many
years it's now coming back around and
trying to vindicate trying to exonerate
leftist politicians who got caught up in
the me2 scandal shows it for just the
absolute hack ideology that it is we'll
get to that in a second then we'll get
to the best new piece of merch of the
2020 campaign we'll get to a OC
endorsing open borders we'll get to
everything but first next month we are
taking our backstage live show on the
road for a special one-night only event
August 21st at the incredible Terrace
theater in Long Beach California who's
it going to involve Ben Shapiro daily
wire guide King Jeremy boring Andrew
Clavin and most important of all me we
will be chopping up the winners and
losers of politics in pop culture
best of all we will be answering your
questions from the audience so make
those questions good tickets are
available at daily wire.com slash
backstage there were still a few VIP
ticket packages available which include
premium seating photos and meet and
greets with each of us you'll get a gift
from Shapiro you will get even more than
that these are the best events of the
year as far as I know this is the only
one that we are going to do this year a
daily wire live we did a couple last
year with Ben and they were just
excellent events and I still get to talk
to some people that we met at that it is
a a great way to to talk and figure out
what you guys are thinking and come on
out and see us head over to Daley
wired.com slash backstage and get your
tickets today also did you hear that
sound it's like bells chiming birds
singing that's because it's almost time
for our next episode of the conversation
featuring the one and only bald bastion
of brilliance
Andrew Clavin who the hell wrote this
stuff but no he is he is actually a very
brilliant man so you should you should
go over don't tell him I said that
tomorrow July 24th at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific drew Clavin will be taking
all of your questions every query that
is burned in your hearts
and he will answer them live on air as
always the episode is free to watch on
Facebook and YouTube but only
subscribers can ask the questions so
subscribe to The Daily wire and get your
questions answered by the supreme leader
of the multiverse and reclaim them
tomorrow at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific and join the conversation
head over to Daley wire.com we'll be
right back
so Miss Michigan refuses to wear this
hijab she says it's a tool of women's
oppression CNN mocks her for it they
smear her is some kind of bigot for it
they don't believe her they won't accept
it just just as a point of fact women
within the last couple years have been
lashed in Saudi Arabia for refusing to
wear not just the hijab but the entire
abaya that entire body cover
they've been lashed publicly for it last
year just in 2018 dozens of women in
Iran were arrested for not wearing the
hijab in just one roundup how many other
women have been arrested for it I'm not
against head coverings in general I
actually kind of like them you know
there's the image of Baptist women
wearing gigantic hats to church the
Catholics have mantillas I always love a
nice Mantia good veiled head covering
I'm not opposed to that what I'm opposed
to is lashing and stoning women for not
covering their heads in public I'm I
think that's bad and that is what miss
michigan is objecting to and that's just
too much for CNN because when it comes
down to it when it comes down to the
woke nests of supporting feminism and
the woke nosov supporting Islam and
that's the new fashion the left is going
to side with Islam they're always moving
the goalposts aren't they they're always
chasing some new victim group even if it
means they have to throw the old victim
group under the bus we'll examine why
we'll see why in just one second but
first the most egregious story on this
front is about Al Franken remember Al
Franken Stuart Smalley from SNL he was a
cast member on SNL and then somehow he
got himself elected to the Senate from
Minnesota and then in the tumult of the
me2 era he got thrown out because he
apparently squeezed a couple women on
the derriere campaign stops actually
more than a couple women according to
the accusations and he got he got thrown
out for that now one of the leaders of
the me to what
chants woman named jane mayer who would
write with Ronan Farrow in The New
Yorker she has come out in The New
Yorker to defend Al Franken to try to
exonerate Al Franken you might remember
that name Jane Mayer as one of the most
egregious smear merchants against Brett
Kavanaugh during his Supreme Court
confirmation hearings here is Jane Mayer
who came up with a completely
uncorroborated story about Brett
Kavanaugh exposing himself one time in a
dorm room at Yale at some party and no
no evidence of this whatsoever no
corroboration whatsoever they published
in The New Yorker it was criticized by
some of us at the time and she goes on
TV and says no problem whatsoever The
New Yorker admits that they were nun
able to confirm with other eyewitnesses
that Cavanaugh was even present at this
party why did you print this story we've
got a woman who was a classmate of his
at Yale who went on the record to
describe her own experience here and
when we started to do more reporting on
it
we found another classmate who remembers
hearing about it that night or the next
day oh so the only corroborating witness
can't even call him a witness is not a
witness the only person that sort of
tries to corroborate this is someone who
heard about it
secondhand so she's getting a third hand
complete nonsense she had heard rumors
about Brett Kavanaugh and breathlessly
reported it in The New Yorker with no
proof whatsoever didn't even have the
accounts just hearsay
now she's defending Al Franken in a new
piece it's about seven zillion words
long I mean she clearly took her time on
this the case of Al Franken a closer
look at the accusations against the
former senator
she writes quote frankenz fall was
stunningly Swift he resigned only three
weeks after Lee Ann tweed a conservative
talk radio host accused him of having
forced an unwanted kiss on her during a
2006 USO tour seven more women followed
with accusations against Franken all of
them centered on inappropriate touches
or kisses half the accusers names still
haven't become public
although both Franken and tweetIn called
for an independent investigation into
her charges
none took place the implication
obviously is that the women are lying
that's why they won't come forward and
Lee aunt Whedon is lying because she's a
conservative talk show host really rich
coming from the woman who smeared brick
Cavanaugh
I'm not saying that Al Franken should
have resigned or that the accusations
against him are true there is infinitely
more evidence against Al Franken then
there was against Brett Kavanaugh there
was nothing against Brett Kavanaugh some
crazy woman said that he pushed her into
a room 30 years ago and she changed her
story five times and and demonstrably
lied to the Senate and that's it and
then some other crazy woman came out of
the woodwork and then she was she was
represented by Michael avenatti she was
completely disproven so they tried to
shut her up quickly then some other
woman from Yale came out and said what I
mean you know that there was no
corroboration no witnesses nobody could
tell you anything about that other than
Jane Mayer hearing it third hand you
know Jane Mayer talks about how the the
main accuser against against Al Franken
was a conservative talk show host the
main accuser against Brett Kavanaugh was
a far left-wing activist who shut down
all of her social media pages because
she was constantly posting about how
much she hated Donald Trump and hated
conservatives and that information was
suppressed during the cabin odd debacle
really really rich but she actually
doesn't even evade the Cavanaugh
comparisons Jane Mayer the hack that she
is goes right for them quote the lawyer
Deborah Katz who has represented
Christine Blasi Ford and other sexual
harassment victims remains troubled by
frankenz case she contends the
allegations leveled against senator
Franken did not warrant his forced
expulsion from the Senate particularly
given the context in which most of the
behavior occurred which was in his
capacity as a comedian oh my gosh she
adds all offensive behavior should be
addressed but not all offensive behavior
warrants the most severe sanction
katzie's Franken is a cautionary tale
for the me2 movement to treat all
allegations the same is not only
inappropriate it feeds into a
a clash narrative that men are
vulnerable to even frivolous allegations
by women says the expert in frivolous
allegations by women
Deborah Katz absolutely outrageous in
the case of Al Franken there is a
photograph of him posing about to grope
a sleeping service member none of that
with Brett Kavanaugh
but but they're hacks I mean Franken was
forced out why was he forced out because
he was replaceable in Minnesota
Democratic governor they knew they could
replace him with a Democrat forced out
by Kirsten Gillibrand she thought she
could make her political bones on it
only he knows what he did if he really
was groping women at every campaign stop
he should leave the Senate but maybe the
allegations weren't true I don't know
we're in this me to madness moment and
you know there are plenty of false
accusations it seems reasonable for him
to have waited it out if he could have
weathered it politically but it's not
reasonable for him to have waited it out
when you've got absolute circuses like
the Brett Kavanaugh hearings it's not
reasonable to let Franken off the hook
when the left is weaponizing sexual
assault charges against men not to the
benefit of women just to railroad their
own political opponents this is misogyny
the left is all for women's rights
unless a Muslim man objects the left is
all for women's rights unless a man in a
dress objects the left is all for
women's rights unless a male Democratic
politician objects and like on so many
issues what is this about it's a it
shows that the left doesn't care about
women at all they don't care about their
nominal victim classes at all
particularly with gender ideology they
seem to hold women in contempt more
broadly what the left does is they they
use victim groups in many cases they
create victim groups to divide to lie
emotionally to lie and emotionally
manipulate them into voting for them
into their political purposes and then
when another shiny object comes along
they ditch the previous victim group I
don't use the phrase misogyny lightly
but this is contempt and disdain for
womanhood for women and for the feminine
conservative
have a unique opportunity to speak out
on this the way to speak about it by the
way is to speak from the perspective of
beauty of love for women not from the
necessarily from rights or some
political doctrine but from beauty you
know conservatives have an advantage
when it comes to speaking about beauty
on the left because the left is this
rationalistic cold clinical
materialistic cult of politics
conservatives are romantics basically we
see the beauty and complexity of the
world and we like it we like the
diversity of the world
Edmund Burke the great founder of modern
conservatism he was a an aesthetic
philosopher - not an aesthetician though
and he never had to wax any dudes in a
dress
conservatives get Beauty better than the
left and I think we can convince people
with a little bit of joy and by showing
them the beauty of this world instead of
this crazy scolding nonsense you know
the left is imploding on this they are
embracing the least popular ideas in the
country and they are they are just
trying to shame people in and
cower people into voting for them out of
fear
here's a Sen a campaign event AFER's
embracing completely open borders
I think migration to me is liberation
it's the ability to move and be it's the
freedom to be really is what we're
talking about and I think that all
people should be free to be here and in
our communities because I think that
when you start viewing human beings as
intrinsically valuable you feel blessed
that they have come to you with their
presence and that's really I think the
shift that we need to make as a country
it's the shift free to be she's like a
like dr. Seuss without the talent we're
free to be to be to me to cross into the
border illegally but we're now going to
make it illegal we're going to
completely decriminalize border
crossings this is very unpopular
president Trump knows this he knows how
unpopular this is at the last debate
every single candidate on that demo
kradic stage endorsed free healthcare
for illegal aliens all their hands go up
we use your hand if covered if your
government plan would provide coverage
for undocumented immigrants
[Applause]
because our country is healthier when
everybody is healthier okay all right
every hand goes up everyone's you know
how popular that proposal is there's a
new poll out right now from NPR PBS
Newshour and Marist which shows that
just 33 percent support health care for
illegal aliens of all Americans
reparations which is another policy the
Democrats are almost universally
endorsing just 27% of Americans support
that how many people do you think
support making immigrant women wax salon
workers wax the male genitals how many
people do you think support that like
two people in the whole world how many
people do you think support taking
scholarships away from high school girls
because they're gonna force them to
compete against men in track how many
people do you think support taking away
miss world USA is miss Michigan's crown
because she refuses to submit to the
hijab like to this is the least popular
stuff on earth and Trump knows this I
remember he did this during the campaign
in 2016 they were trying to cower him
into saying to stop using the word
anchor baby and this and that words
offensive and you and Trump said what do
you want me to use and the guy he said I
you know future American dreamer
undocumented dreaming Trump looks at him
like he's stupid he says you know I
think I'm gonna stick with the anchor
baby and I people react to that and he's
back the best piece of merch in 2020 it
Trump is now selling plastic straws on
his website because I don't know about
where you live but where I live here on
the left coast it's now illegal you
can't have straws you can only have
those paper straws that turn into goop
within two seconds of whatever you're
drinking they don't work President Trump
is now selling Trump straws pack of ten
and here's the description liberal paper
straws don't work stand with President
Trump buy your pack of recyclable straws
today this is brilliant same with the
pronouns it's an apparently trivial
thing but it actually stands for so much
it is so much in the way of premises and
this is what I think people are reacting
to I mean this is what I suspect people
are reacting to
what kind of government tells you what
straws you're allowed to drink your
coffee out of or your coca-cola what
kind of overbearing government what kind
of absurd government thinks that plastic
straws are the biggest problem in the
world worth the strength of the state
and suppressing people's freedom what
kind of sick government goes in and
forces immigrant women to fondle men's
genitals because the men say so
what kind of sick government does that
what kind of sick government comes in
and says open borders anybody can come
in I don't care what you people think I
don't care what you people want well
that's this fantasy there's a leftist
fantasy which is now ironically the Left
prattles on about the war on women the
left has become misogynistic as they
ditch their old victim groups they just
move on and embrace further fantasy
after fantasy after fantasy what
President Trump is doing is he's not
campaigning on some broad health care
proposal he's not campaigning on some
really specific tax proposal that all
the wonks at all the think tanks have
have passed approval on he's campaigning
on hey immigrant women shouldn't have to
wax men's genitals
hey you should be able to drink your
coca-cola out of a straw hey we should
be able to have borders because this is
a country's campaigning on the most
basic elements the most basic intuitions
of a people in a free self governing
society but in this bizarro Fantasyland
of extreme left ISM none of that is
permitted anymore and it's so when
President Trump says a very basic things
such as that it's deemed politically
incorrect and I think he's he's got his
finger on the pulse of the people in
this way the only question is can he
keep his foot out of his mouth for long
enough
to not offend those who might be able to
come over and and be his allies because
the way that conservatives are gonna win
it's not by talking in some highly
technical egghead kind of terms it's
gonna be by talking about basic things
goodness truth beauty those those basic
intuitions and longings we have right
now we're doing
well and and if the Democratic primary
debates are any indication I think we're
gonna keep doing it well going into 2020
but we'll have to see all more tomorrow
in the meantime I'm headed to DC I'll be
speaking at TP USA I'll be speaking at
ya and I'll be hanging around the
Capitol so come say hey if I see you
around there in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show presidents from signs
off on a debt breaking budget deal
Democrats make more grand promises and a
transgender woman says it's time for you
to wax his balls that's today on the
bench Shapiro show